vor genau 70 jahren erschienen
frankreich ein werk das die moderne welt
erschütterte und veränderte sein titel
das andere geschlecht seine autorin
simon de bach über leben und werk dieser
einflussreichsten philosophin des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts hat kate kirk
patrick nun eine neue bahnbrechende
biografie geschrieben zeit also den
mythos buch noch einmal neu zu
besichtigen und zu bewerten frau per
klick herzlich willkommen das tanzt und
jetzt habe ich wieder journalisten zu
tun ein superlativ angewendet die
einflussreichste philosophin des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts stimmt dass für
den fall war überhaupt das ist eine sehr
schwierige frage weil ich nicht weiß was
es bedeutet die einflussreichste
philosophen zu sein und wie man das
messen könnte aber es stimmt dass ihr
buch das andere geschlecht bereits zu
ihrer lebzeit einen großen einfluss
hatte bis 1980 wurden mehr als eine
million exemplare verkauft
es wurde weltweit in viele sprachen
übersetzt und prägt bis heute viele
feministische theorien und die
politische arbeit des feminismus
aber wo war's einfluss geht weit über
das andere geschlecht hinaus ihre
philosophischen und biographischen texte
haben maßgeblich zur ausgestaltung des
französischen existenzialismus
beigetragen und entfalteten insbesondere
unter den leserinnen eine große wirkung
wenn wir mal bei diesem einfluss dieses
buches bleiben eine million verkaufte
exemplare eine weltweite wirkung könnte
man sagen dass unser art und weise zu
leben heute zwischen den geschlechtern
eine andere wäre wenn es dieses buch
nicht geben ja absolut
ungeachtet der absicht die man dazu
schrieb war das andere geschlecht ein
irritierendes buch
begrüßt wurde weil es eine neue sicht
auf die welt ermöglichte die kritik der
verhältnisse zwischen mann und frau in
ihrer kultur ging aber vielen zu weit
die darauf mit wut und zorn reagierten
diese veränderung hat widerstand
hervorgerufen
aber bevor wir zu den wirklich kommen es
ist ja auch deswegen eine interessante
frage die frage nach der philosophin boa
weil diese frau fast ihr gesamtes
erwachsenenleben bestritten hat eine
philosophie zu sein
wie kommt das eigentlich nun sie hat in
einigen berühmten passagen tatsächlichen
abrede gestellt eine philosophin zu sein
die aussage in einigen ihrer memoiren
wonach sie im gegensatz zur seite eine
schriftstellerin sei stellt viele
feministinnen bis heute vor rätsel
einige sehen die art und weise wie sie
sich selber von der philosophie
ausschloss als internalisiert misogynie
internalisiert misogynie heißt dass sie
ihre eigene rolle als zweites geschlecht
angenommen hat und gesagt ich kann gar
nicht so gut denken man könnte daraus
lesen dass die philosophie eine
männersache wäre und nichts für sie ein
vertiefter blick in das werk zeigt aber
dass sie schon sehr früh in ihrem leben
der philosophie verschrieben hat auch
der dokumentarfilm von dschidda jung
profitiert sie als philosophin
sie lehnte hier und an anderen orten wo
sie auf den wortlaut die einfluss nehmen
können die bezeichnung nicht ab
die aussage in ihren biografischen
texten sie sei verglichen mit star trek
eine philosophin kann auch als
herabwürdigung von patrice philosophie
gelesen werden
sie unterscheidet er zwischen
verschiedenen arten der philosophie wie
man aus einem ihrer essays der 40er
jahre literatur und metaphysik weiß wo
sie system philosophen und subjektivität
philosophen abgrenzt und sie würde er
eine subjektivität philosophin sein als
eine system philosophin sie haben es ja
gesagt es gibt da einen großen an
einen großen gleichen innova das leben
der etwas damit zu tun hat dass sie sich
zur philosophie eher schüchtern äußerte
bei diesen menschen aktiv 50 jahre ihr
lieben ihr leben ihr denken geteilt jean
porträt wir sehen die beiden hier in
einer ikonischen darstellung wie
sinnvoll ist es eigentlich wo er als
philosophin von der präsenz und dem
einfluss von saab zu trennen was für
eine tolle frage die unterscheidung des
philosophen sarah und der philosophie
ist sinnvoll weil sie nicht dasselbe
dachte ich habe über bevor in der form
einer biografie geschrieben weil ich mir
so die art fragen ansehen konnte diese
philosophisch beschäftigten bevor sie
sie ihres denkens ihres denkens als die
studentin war in den 1920 er jahren als
sie sich trafen war sie ja gerade mal 21
sie hatte aber bereits sehr klare ideen
zu themen wie freiheit oder liebe denen
sie in ihrem späteren werktreue und
führte sie dann bekannt wurde
die unterscheidung zwischen der
philosophie von bo und sarah ist auch
sinnvoll aufgrund der heftigen
geringschätzung die sie erfuhr
wenn etwa abschätzig gesagt wurde dass
alle sind das andere geschlecht der
philosophie sei es zu verdanken wäre
oder dass ihr talent einzig darin
bestünde seine ideen verständlich zu
machen
es gibt keine belege für diese hypothese
in ihrem buch bekam ingo war das jetzt
im april dann auch auf deutsch unter dem
titel simon war ein modernes leben
erscheint wird betonen sie die
kontinuität in wo was denkt weg schon
lange bevor sie sah traf aber man kann
ja auch sagen das war jetzt von mir
schon so eine frage die komisch ist und
anders herum nie gestellt wurde
man fragt wie kann man eigentlich sah
das denken von novalis unterscheiden
das heißt es gibt eigentlich schon in
der wahrnehmung dieses pärchens eine art
sexistische verzerrung kann man sich ja
absolut
in meiner einleitung erwähne ich dass
die beiden als intellektuelles power
couple bekannt sind
bis heute hält sich das klischee wonach
er die intellektuelle kraft war und sie
das paar aus machte zwar räumt man ein
dass sie gut schreiben konnte aber
sowohl bei ihren philosophischen texten
wie auch der erzählliteratur monierte
man einen mangel an einfallsreichtum
ein nachruf bezeichnete sie als so
einfallslos wie ihr tintenfass das ist
entschieden nicht erfüllen mit blick auf
ihr frühwerk zeigt sich wie erwähnt die
kontinuität ihres denkens schon vor
sagte aber man sieht auch wie ihre ideen
des denkens beeinflussen
in der akademischen welt findet das über
die forschung zur boa der letzten 30
jahre auch zunehmend anerkennung
es ist nicht richtig durchgedrungen in
die öffentlichkeit
eine wunderschöne schlussfolgerung und
auch eine problematisch in ihrem buch
lautet folgendermaßen ganz am ende
boa war auch die gefangenen
gesellschaftlicher vorurteile ihr leben
ist ein paradebeispiel für die
doppelstandards den frauen unterworfen
werden
vor allem für die art und weise in der
frauen abgestraft werden wenn sie es
wagen die wahrheit beim namen zu nennen
was sind denn sehr sehr markante
beispiele für diesen doppel standard die
bewertung des pärchens in ihrer
bedeutung ist eines kann man da noch
mehr nennen unter der sie gelitten hat
bis heute leidet am offensichtlichsten
das wofür goar und st berühmt geworden
sind eine offene beziehung zu führen in
den 19 30
jahren eine sexuelle auch offene
beziehung ja was wir heute als holy moly
bezeichnen würden zur liebesgeschichte
von setra und bewahre gehört dass sie
sich 1929 vor dem karussell die louvre
versprachen einander notwendige
lebenspartner zu sein es aber in ordnung
wäre daneben weitere liebespartner zu
haben
diese verbindung einer bestimmten form
von treue mit freiheit in der beziehung
hat viele inspiriert für manche dieser
falls lieben insbesondere junge frauen
mit denen sie in den dreißiger jahren
beziehungen eingingen hatte das aber
sehr negative folgen
interessant finde ich die asymmetrie der
wahrnehmung und bewertung dieser
verhältnisse beide waren zarko war hatte
diese beziehungen befuhr sie das andere
geschlecht schrieb und sie bedauerte und
verurteilte diese später in ihren texten
zur beatles athris texten erkenne ich
nicht in diesem maße ein bedauern oder
eine verurteilung eines unmoralischen
verhaltens hat das sieht man ja auch wie
die engel verschaltung von
lebenserfahrung und theorie entwicklung
bei bupa funktioniert das ist ja für den
existenzialismus ganz wichtig den sie
dann auch mit entwickelt dass es nicht
nur eine philosophie dass es eine art
und weise das eigene leben zu gestalten
ja absolut sie strebte eine starke
verschränkung von denken und leben an
zu bestimmten zeiten versuchte sie einer
bestimmten vorstellung von freiheit oder
liebe nach zu leben wie sie herausfand
dass dies nicht funktionierte
gerade weil boa den einklang zwischen
ihrem leben und ihrer philosophie sucht
lohnt sich eine biografische annäherung
an ihr leben in bestimmten phasen sah
sie sich selbst als in widerspruch zu
ihrer philosophie als veränderungs und
verbesserungsbedürftig
es ist interessant diesen reflektiven
prozess zeitlich in den tagebüchern und
briefen zu verfolgen in ihrer biografie
legen sehr großen wert auf diese früh
vater ihres denkens und auch auf die
phase von uns hat 29
zum ausbruch des ersten weltkrieges als
die wirklich wichtigen jahre ihrer
gedanklichen entwicklung und eine
wichtige phase ist das ja auch der
sexuellen befreiung in der sich bruder
als frau in ihrer in ihrem begehren
selbst entdeckt wie würden sie sagen ist
in diesem projekt der
existenzialistischen befreiung der sex
und die sexuelle befreiung welche rolle
spielt hätte ein projekt des
existenzialismus und auch in der idee
dass man sich selbst als person entwirft
die antwort auf diese frage hängt vom
zeitpunkt ab es gibt eine phase in der
wie war ihr verhalten als nur auf sich
selbst bezogen bezeichnung bei der
übrigens in dieser frühphase unser 29 wo
sich gerade als paar gefunden und
kennengelernt haben ein bisschen ein
ungleiches paar sieht man gleich aber
auch sympathisch
ja das ist ein lustiges foto sie waren
an einem jahrmarkt und mit dem schuss
wurde auch ein foto gemacht deshalb die
zugekniffenen augen
sie sagten das kommt auf die phase an
den wie man diese sexuelle
befreiungsbewegung ja aber man muss vor
1929 ansetzen
sie wurde streng katholisch erzogen und
hatte was man in der christlichen
tradition einen odium
körperfeindlichkeit hatte sie teilweise
von ihrer mutter auch vom katholizismus
ich glaube es ist nicht ganz fair den
katholizismus mit dem breiten pinsel zu
malen weil nicht alle sind diese
kategorie fällt aber es stimmt dass in
ihrer kindheit der körper ein tabu
darstellt als sie aus dieser sehr
eingeschnitten kindheit in ihr eigenes
leben und das mit zarter eintauchte gab
es einen prozess der rebellion und
selbstbehauptung der für ihr leben und
die entwicklung ihres denkens eine sehr
wichtige rolle spielte
in ihrer gereiften sicht der 40er jahre
begriff sie sexualität nicht nur als
etwas selbst bezogenes sondern auch als
etwas ethisch zu bewertendes weil
sexuelle beziehungen zusammen mit
anderen geschehen 29 sie sprachen es an
dieser takt zwischen beiden und da ist
es ja sogar so dass sarah anbietet sie
zu heiraten und sie sagt nein ich will
das nicht das würde uns weiter um frei
machen ich will auch keine kinder
das ist ja eine art rollenmodell
geworden als idee wie man eine frau als
frau und 20 jahrhundert eine beziehung
führt und es passiert dann aber 1938 37
noch etwas anderes sie sprachen es an
der bar entdeckt ihre bisexualität und
geht einige beziehungen ein auch mit
ehemaligen oder aktuellen schülerinnen
von ihr denn sie war gymnasiallehrerin
zu gehen sei ja sie hat die beziehungen
sowohl mit männern wie auch mit frauen
als existenzialist in glaubte sie aber
dass sexualität in einer situation
zwischen zwei bestimmten individuen
geschieht
sie würde sich selbst also nicht
unbedingt als bisexuell bezeichnet haben
interessanterweise sagte sie als sie
später einmal gefragt wurde was sie
anders machen würde dass sie über ihre
sexualität aus feministischer
perspektive berichten würde ich glaube
sie war sich ihre eigenen verwirrung
bewusst dass ja auch nicht zugegeben
dass es auch lesbische beziehungen ihrem
leben kam sie hat das lange verneint und
auch verhielt ja stimmt und dafür gibt
es verschiedene mögliche auch rechtliche
gründe
es gab zwar in frankreich noch keine
gesetze zum schutz der privatsphäre in
der heutigen form
trotzdem konnte man in seinen memoiren
nicht einfach über sexuelle partner
schreiben ohne deren privatsphäre zu
achten
es gibt viele mögliche gründe weshalb
sie diese beziehungen verheimlichte sie
haben ja was wunderbares gesagt ich
glaube darauf sollte eingehen weil es
hier nicht darum geht schmutzige wäsche
zu waschen sondern darum dass diese
erfahrungen für sie philosophisch eine
große bedeutung hat
insbesondere die frage was hat meine
eigene freiheit mit den freiheiten
anderer zu tun und es gab ja da eine
erfahrung oder einige erfahrungen die
ein bisschen problematische zeit
häufiger in heutiger sicht es war
nämlich so das bo war beziehungen zu
schülerinnen von ihr aufnahmen und diese
schülerinnen dann sollen wir sagen
weitergab an sarah als geliebte sie
sagen sind da ein bisschen wohlwollend
würde ich sagen sie sagen man weiß nicht
richtig was sie gedacht hatte sie sagen
das war nicht illegal es war konsensual
aber heute in der zeit von mi to würde
man sagen da haben zwei ältere macht
personen jüngere frauen sexuell
ausgenutzt
ich bin nicht einverstanden dass ich dem
wohlwollend begegnen
tatsächlich billige ich dieses tun nicht
gegenwärtig herrscht aber die tendenz
die vergangenheit durch die brille der
heutigen moral oder der moral eines
bestimmten kontext zu betrachten
ich sehe es auch nicht als die aufgabe
des biografen über sein subjekt zu
urteilen sondern den sachverhalt
darzulegen um den lesern ein eigenes
urteil zu ermöglichen
es herrschten andere umstände mich
interessiert eher das buch ihr eigenes
verhalten verurteilt hat und ihre
formulierung weitergab wird den
umständen nicht gerecht hofer und sarah
betrachteten diese individuen als
personen die durchaus in der lage waren
eigene entscheide zu treffen
gemäss ihrer damaligen idee der freiheit
waren sie frei miteinander oder mit
anderen zu schlafen
persönlich finde ich diese dynamik sehr
problematisch philosophisch aber ist es
interessant dass boa in ihrem umgang mit
diesen frauen einen gewissen solis muss
erkannte der von eigeninteresse
motiviert waren in der philosophischen
traditionen die frage ob andere menschen
überhaupt so existieren und so wichtig
sind wie ich es für mich will
es geht um die frage inwieweit die
erfahrung des anderen in meine
abwägungen zum eigenen handeln einfließt
gemäss bevor aus einschätzung wurde den
erfahrungen dieser anderen nicht das
richtige moralische gewicht zuteil
diese beziehungen flossen in einzelne
passagen im anderen geschlecht ein wo
sie über die dynamik ungleicher liebe
spricht das andere geschlecht stützt
sich also nicht nur auf ihre
heterosexuellen erfahrungen die
klarerweise ungleichen beziehungen mit
diesen studentinnen und ihre ethischen
reflektionen darüber haben auch eingang
gefunden in dieses buch in der
systematischen entwicklung des
existenzialismus als strömung ist das ja
eine ganz ganz wichtige schnittstelle
die db hat erkannt und ausgearbeitet hat
nämlich meine freiheit mein entwurf mein
ergreifen meiner selbst und die
wirkungen auf andere und die bedeutung
des anderen für diesen entwurf und das
beginnt so in dieser 1938 39 phase
aufgrund von persönlichen
zwischenmenschlicher vor immer noch gar
nicht politische erfahrungen sondern
wirklich leben privatlebens
angelegenheiten
ich glaube es ist eine mischung die
tiere ihre tagebücher als studentin le
carré genies enthalten bereits 1926 eine
diskussion zu reziprozität und liebe sie
beobachtet in vielen liebesbeziehungen
einen mangel an reziprozität das ist
sehr bedeutsam denn ende der 40er jahre
für zara in seinen entwürfen für eine
moralphilosophie das konzept der
positiven reziprozität ein positive
wechselseitigkeit könnte
ja er hat diesen gedanken also bereits
in den 20er jahren in den dreißiger
jahren lebt sie viel und schreibt ihr
wenig erst wieder ende der dreißiger und
der 40er jahre finden sich
dokumentarische hinweise aber es ist
sehr schwierig all die erfahrungsebene
zu entflechten die zu einer neuen
betrachtungsweise früherer erlebnisse
führten
aber was ist denn eigentlich jetzt im
kern gefasst das philosophische problem
ich habe vorstellung davon wie ich mein
leben führen will
die anderen haben andere vorstellungen
wie kommt der gedanke der dann für boa
so wichtig wird meine freiheit kann nur
wirklich freiheit sein wenn ich die
gleiche freiheit für andere auch
ermöglichen wie die easter systematisch
zu verstehen als gedanken entwicklung
nun nach nietzsches umwertung aller
werte und der frage wie man wenn
überhaupt eine ethik ohne gott oder
irgendeine transzendenz begründen könnte
sieht bot die antwort in der freiheit
die freiheit begründet alle weiteren
werte wenn man die eigene freiheit
schätzt muss man konsequenterweise die
freiheit des anderen hochhalten
praktisch ist aber nicht klar wie das
funktionieren soll
weil der begriff freiheit die menschen
zu radikal anderen schlussfolgerungen zu
führen scheint in ihren späteren es
wendet sie sich stärker der politik und
der geschichte zu in den späten
dreißigern und den frühen vierzigern
ließen die kriegssituation und das
besetzte paris sie ihre eigene
kompliziert in der weltgeschichte
erkennen
man kann ja sagen dass diese besetzung
paris für sie eine art politisches
erwachen war dann erst begreift sie sich
schon 30 jahre alten eltern dass sie
auch ein politisches subjekt ist dass
sie nicht nur ihr privatleben hat
sondern eingebunden ist ein
die größeren zusammenhang ja es gab
dieses erwachen
es wird oft über bewahre behauptet dass
sie unpolitisch war dieses angesichts
ihres lebens unfaire urteil geht
vielleicht auf passagen in ihren
memoiren zurück wo sie beschreibt wie
sata aus der kriegsgefangenschaft als
ein anderer zurückkehrt während sie
beide vor dem krieg in ihrer geisteswelt
der literatur und philosophie lebten
geht es nach seiner rückkehr um fragen
wie den beitritt zur kommunistischen
partei frankreichs war durchaus
politisch nur befasste sie sich oft mit
frauen kindern und älteren menschen oder
in den 50er jahren den algeriern ihre
politik ganz marginalisierten gruppen
und nicht den politikern mit denen es
örtlich tritt heute so eine art
wahrnehmungs kritik heraus dass wenn
eine frau sich für kinder für
frauenrechte einsetzt dass man das nicht
als ein politisches engagement war dem
sondern irgendetwas was auch schön ist
aber nicht wirklich die großen fragen
berührt diese ansicht war im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert sicher weit verbreitet in
ihrem wunderbaren buch über das alter
das 1970 veröffentlicht wurde
als sie schon marxistischer geworden war
sagt sie dass das problem bei den
kindern oder den älteren darin besteht
dass sie noch nicht oder nicht mehr
männer sind politik soll sich folglich
mit dem ökonomisch produktiven mann
befassen
es geht diese normativität also im
prinzip politik ist politik die die
bedürfnisse und fähigkeiten eines weißen
mannes bespricht und alles andere ist
vielleicht wichtig aber nicht sehr
wichtig das ist natürlich eine karikatur
aber sie war alles andere als
unpolitisch die art wie ihre literatur
wahrgenommen wurde zeigt inwieweit die
anliegen von frau und marginalisiert und
klein gemacht wurden als eine gebrochene
frau eine sammlung von drei
kurzgeschichten geschrieben aus der
frauenperspektive herausgegeben wurde
bemängelte die kritik dass es keine
männer in diesem buch gab literatur an
die fragen würden natürlich ist es ja
auch interessant diese mythischen jahre
sagen ihr 43 44 paris befreit sagte komm
zurück die großen jahre des
existenzialismus für kubas an dass auch
jahre eines wandels sie schreibt
eigentlich kurzgeschichten sie schreibt
einen roman und dann passiert was sie
wird selbst zu einer art systematischen
philosophin die die frage nach dem
anderen und der freiheit des anderen ins
zentrum stellt und sie ist nicht einig
mit zarten sie streiten darüber eine
große streitfrage sie erwähnen dass er
in ihrem buch ist zum beispiel wie frei
kann eine frau in einem harem sein start
würde sagen da gibt es immer noch viel
entscheidungsfreiheit und wo war in
dieser situation gibt es keine freiheit
und wir sollten auch nicht so reden wie
sie zweifelt sein konzept von freiheit
an
in büros und 10er ist ein buch das ein
jahr nach sarahs sein und nichts
veröffentlicht wurde kritisiert sie es
explizit indem sie sagt dass man wieder
guard am gegensatz von freiheit und
macht festhalten müsse wir alle haben
die metaphysische freiheit menschen zu
sein nicht aber die konkrete macht die
uns die möglichkeiten zur realisierung
unsere entwürfe gibt
sie nutzt auch die erzählliteratur auf
interessante weise um das problem
fiktionalisiert zu erörtern
ihre kritik das konzept der freiheit
verfasst sie früh in den 40er jahren
und es ist erstaunlich wie produktiv sie
war von 1943 bis zum ende dieses
jahrzehnts
sie war immer schon produktiv aber diese
phase ist besonders intensiv mit essays
über den existenzialismus und der
gemeinsamen herausgabe der dom oder das
ist die zeitschrift erscheint unter der
herausgabe von vom vater und wo war und
sie machen den punkt ich glaube das ist
ein punkt der sehr wichtig ist auch in
der nacherzählung eigentlich ist ist sie
die mit ihrem gedankengut sei überhaupt
zu einer philosophie der ethik bewegt
genau
sie fehlten heftige streit gespräche und
ihre beziehung wurde auch so geschrieben
von einem gemeinsamen bekannten aus den
dreißiger jahren
sie waren philosophen und das birgt denn
die sense insel durch die kritische
begleitung der arbeit des anderen haben
sie sich gegenseitig motiviert die dinge
stets in einem neuen licht zu sehen aber
sie hat seine ethik nie zu lebzeiten
veröffentlicht wir kennen heute das
geboren moral seine notizen zur ethik
die er 19 47 48 verfasste vieles davon
erinnert an büros und ziehen es aber
auch an für eine moral der
zweideutigkeit von bo war ab ende der
40er jahre gab es also gemeinsame
anliegen auch wenn sie sich der frage
nach der unterdrückung der anderen auf
unterschiedliche art näherten hat sich
im es überlegungen zur judenfrage und im
aufsatz schwarzer orpheus gedanken
gemacht zu antisemitismus und rassismus
boah veröffentlichte dann 1949 das
andere geschlecht
ich finde sampras theoretischen
erklärungsansatz zur art und weise
die unterdrückung zustande kommt und
sich manifestiert weniger überzeugend
als beweis sie sagten dass 1949 nach
dreijähriger arbeit intensiver arbeit
erscheint dieses merkel oder 76 auf
deutsch das andere geschlecht und
systematisch kann man sagen die frage
nach dem anderen wird auf die
strukturelle frage nach der rolle der
frau angewendet und es kommt heraus dass
die frau nicht nur ein anderes
geschlechtes sondern ein unterbewertetes
strukturell in ihrer bewertung als
menschliches wesen immer zweitrangig
deswegen das dossier m6 das zweite das
ist der kern der diagnose frauen sind in
gewisser weise menschen zweiter wahl wie
männer nur nicht ganz so gut
es ist sehr interessant wie der titel in
andere sprachen übersetzt wurde
wo war betont dass es nicht um das
anderssein geht
wichtiger als die dornier physiologie
die einen unterschied ausmachen
die körperlichen unterschiede zwischen
mann und frau
wichtiger ist die unterordner des
anderen
der erste band untersucht was die
menschheit mit dem weiblichen menschen
gemacht hat sie zeigt auf dass die ideen
der selbstentfaltung und freiheit ein
entwicklungs ideal kann man sagen für
jedes individuum ja das entwicklungs
ideal das den männern angeboten wird im
hinblick auf ihre entwürfe für ein
sinnvolles menschliches leben sich von
dem unterscheidet was den frauen als ihr
schicksal präsentiert wird um einen
begriff zu verwenden den buga selber
benutzt eine aussage ist besonders
interessant und wohl nicht ganz aus der
zeit gefallen
eine frau wird gesagt dass es ihr
schicksal ist zu lieben
hier liegt ihre oberste berufung
wenn es ihr lebensentwurf ist karriere
zu machen oder zu schreiben oder wenn
sie den erwartungen von 1949 zur
mutterschaft oder zur geliebten nicht
entspricht wird sie trotz allen erfolgs
als versagerin gesehen nur als liebende
kann eine frau erfolgreich sein und das
hat immer damit zu tun dass man sich in
gewisser weise um andere kümmert das
heißt ein leben im spiegel und in der
widmung an zu anderen menschen und
sobald das nicht geschieht ist man als
frauen irgendeiner form insuffizienz
richtig im buch spielt sie mit dem
existenzialistischen jargon und fügt dem
für sich sein und dem an sich seien dem
bewusstsein als solchem
das für andere sein hinzu sie sagt
frauen werden ermutigt für männer da zu
sein
das ist nicht nur visuell und sexuell
gemeint ihr leben hat darin zu bestehen
die entwürfe die hre zu unterstützen die
empfänger ihrer liebe sind im hinblick
auf nietzsche und holz die das
bewundernswerte ideal der sich
aufopfernden frau preisen fragt sie wenn
das ein solch wunderbares schicksal ist
warum wollen die männer das nicht auch
sie haben ja gerade gesagt die
beschreibung der frau als in gewisser
weise das art von menschlichen wesen das
sich anderen widmet andere kümmert
andere betreut das ist ja heute im
feminismus auch ein aktuelles thema wenn
man zum beispiel den care begriff nennt
wie man sich um andere kümmert und viele
feministin sagen wir brauchen eine
höhere bewertung dieses aspektes der
zuwendung zu anderen man kann man sagen
einerseits versteht man dass
andererseits feldmann tochter genau und
das beschreibung muster hinein
das boa freie liegt
dass diese frage feministinnen heute in
zweit ist interessant beziehungen werden
manchmal auf die gebende und den
nehmenden reduziert in heterosexuellen
beziehungen wird das ja üblicherweise
geschlechtsspezifisch gesehen wobei der
mann der neben der und die frau die
gebende ist eine solche sichtweise finde
ich unbefriedigend weil wir uns ja nicht
in der heterosexuellen liebesbeziehung
erschöpfen außerhalb gibt es ja noch
ältere menschen kinder oder freunde die
unsere zuwendung benötigen dies nur in
bezug auf paarbeziehungen zu betrachten
ohne berücksichtigung anderer
beziehungen scheint mir problematisch
überspitzt zu dass ihre antwort darin
besteht nicht zugeben aber dass sie ihre
antwort ist reziprozität zu erwarten
in der liebesbeziehung besteht die
ethische antwort nicht darin dass geben
einzustellen sondern eine beziehung zu
führen in der beide partner die entwürfe
des anderen mittragen und sie dabei
unterstützen die zu werden die sie sein
möchten
es ist interessant diese
wechselseitigkeit als ideal das hat er
dann gewisse karriere gemacht
im 20 jahrhundert man kann aber auch
sagen in ihrer eigenen beziehung zu
sarah hat sie sich trotzdem eigentlich
immer in die rolle des kunden begeben
während bei sabre sophie kümmern nicht
immer zu sehen war
ja es ist interessant da sie ja das
konzept der selbsttäuschung mit
beeinflusste beim lesen ihrer biografie
oder ihrer eigenen lebensbeschreibung
ist man versucht zu denken dass sie zu
bestimmten zeiten
der selbsttäuschung unterlag auch hier
verweise ich darauf dass man als biograf
nicht urteilen sollen aber das legen sie
schon auch klar frage das ist eine
spannung gibt ja einer dieser zentralen
sätze und viele große bücher haben es an
sich dass sie auf einen satz
zusammengeschmolzen werden können der
ist bei das andere geschlecht bei bucher
an sich man wird nicht als frau geboren
man wird zu ihr gemacht was genau ist
die kraft und die wirkung dieses satzes
für sie ich lese diesen satz im kontext
des gesamten buches aber auch vor dem
hintergrund des französischen diskurses
über freiheit
er erscheint auf der ersten seite des
zweiten bandes des anderen geschlechts
kam zuerst muss man sagen
im ersten band mit dem titel fakten und
mythen untersucht sie die frauen von der
warte des historischen materialismus der
psychoanalyse biologie und literatur
definiert werden
sie sagt dieses bild der frau dass wir
haben entspricht der sicht einiger
männer dabei verallgemeinert sie nicht
es ist ein stark kulturell verortete
text die literatur teile umfassen
diskussionen zustande mozzarella und
bludenz schon langweilig zu lesen nun
als teil der literatenszene der 40er
jahre hätten sie diese passagen mit
großem interesse gelesen aber es handelt
sich wie gesagt um einen stark kulturell
verorteten text sie ermittelt aus diesen
verschiedenen ansätzen und die
vorstellung der frau weil sie wissen
will was die menschheit mit dem
weiblichen menschen gemacht hat im
zweiten band mit dem titel die geliebte
erfahrung untersucht sie wie es ist eine
frau zu werden innerhalb dieser
kulturellen erwartungen
sie sagt dass er es angesichts der
vielen widersprüchlichen mythen zum frau
seien schwierig ist
eine frau zu sein also eine zentrale
einsicht ist dass die frau nicht das
wesen hat das naturell vorgegeben werde
sondern dass es unsere erzählungen
darüber sind was es eine frau ausmachen
soll
die die frau in ihrem freiheitsdrang
einschränkt diese lesart ist
insbesondere in der angelsächsischen
welt beliebt man sagt oft über das
andere geschlecht das bewahre hier
zwischen sex und gender unterscheidet
allerdings verwendet sie den begriff
gender nicht denn das französische
sondre ist ein linguistischer begriff da
muss man nochmal zur klärung
sex ist das biologische geschlecht und
gender ist die kulturelle konstruktion
die mit den browsern einhergeht
seit seiner veröffentlichung ist das
andere geschlecht unterschiedlich
gelesen worden
einige verstehen diesen satz so dass man
zur frau werden kann egal welches
biologische geschlecht man hat die
schriftstellerin novoa verwendet aber
oft das mittel der anti phrase eine form
der ironie
sie nimmt berühmte tags der
französischen philosophie und literatur
und verändert ein oder zwei wärter auf
sie
sie ließ es gab einen philosophen der
freiheit und des determinismus der ende
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts ziemlich
bekannt war
alfred foyer der mehrere bücher über die
freiheit als eine idee fort schrieb für
ihn war der gedanke der freiheit
besonders kraftvoll weil der drang nach
freiheit sich gegenüber anderen anliegen
durchsetzen würde
darf ich mal kurz nachfragen weil diese
idee der freiheit der wahl
die existenzialisten sagen ja auch
dieser wunderbare satz die existenz geht
der essence voraus nichts ist bestimmt
ich wähle die art und weise wie und wer
ich bin
das hat ja dann im feminismus des 20 21
das eine ziemliche karriere gemacht so
dass man wirklich sagte und einige
feministen haben das gesagt die art und
weise wie ich mich selbst geschlecht ich
verstehe ist vollkommen meine wahl
es gibt da keine biologische grundierung
das ist aber nicht das und das ist auch
nicht der standpunkt von kuba das heißt
sie sagt es gibt eine biologische
grundlage die es wichtig und dieses
ideal der ganz freien quasi luftleeren
wahl meiner geschlecht das dax das geht
zu weit
ja ich bin mit dieser darstellung
einverstanden
im französischen text spricht sie über
die dornier physiologie also über
körperliche gegebenheiten weite teile
des zweiten bandes thematisieren dinge
wie menstruation und schwangerschaft als
physiologische prozesse und potenziale
die zu einem bestimmten biologischen
geschlecht gehören das schrieb sie 1949
aber sie sagt explizit dass sie versucht
einen mittelweg zu gehen zwischen dem
nominal ismus und dem essential es muss
also die art und weise dass man alles
tun könnte und die fahrt und weise dass
es da gegebenheiten gibt die nicht zu
überbrücken und so alfred für
zurückzukommen
er sagt in seiner philosophie der
freiheit dass man nicht frei geboren
wird sondern frei wird
ähnliche formulierungen finden sich auch
in anderen kontexten mit bezug auf steam
user der auch sehr starken einfluss auf
boa hatte wenn man das andere geschlecht
im hinblick auf ihre ethischen schriften
der 40er jahre liest wo sie eine
philosophie entwickeln will die geliebt
werden kann und die berücksichtigt was
es bedeutet ein ethisches selbst zu
werden wird klar dass sie glaubt frauen
stehen beim entwickeln eines ethischen
selbst vor besonderen herausforderungen
weil die ideale der weiblichkeit die
ihnen auferlegt werden es ihnen schwer
machen ihre entwürfe zu verfolgen und
auch mit körperlichen gegebenheiten zu
tun haben die sie auch genannt haben wie
groß dieses projekt einer befreiung der
frau vorbei war eigentlich gedacht wurde
schauen wir uns mal im original an
da legt sie das nämlich kurz nach der
veröffentlichung in aller breite da
demonstrationen haben sie die politiker
die politiker haben interesse aus dem
blau voraus was geld haben müssen gab er
forderte die video sieht man ja
landespolitik europäisches ziel qualität
politik zu betreiben was könnte politik
cep ball an bord geht dann wird die
supermärkte die ratifikation das
katapult depression
die wunschbox saisontreffer telia
duschen
wir sehen hier wo war schon in einer
späteren phase sie und vater sind
politisch globaler aktivisten geworden
haben sich zum sozialismus zum marxismus
teilweise bekannt und hätten das gefühl
das geht eigentlich nur mit einer
umfassenden weltrevolution und sie fängt
an mit der befreiung der frau seien ein
unglaubliches umfassendes politisches
projekt wird daraus das geschah so
einige ist zwischen den 40er jahren und
den späten 60er jahren bei den
forschungsarbeiten zu dieser biografie
fand ich es faszinierend und
inspirierend zu sehen das buch als
reaktion auf das andere geschlecht sehr
viele briefe erhielt
moment 20.000 habe ich gelesen ja es
waren über 20.000 mit einem deutlichen
kippeffekt im moment schaut sich martin
rouge eine großartige forscherin diese
briefe an
in vielen briefen direkt nach dem
erscheinen des buches wurde kritisiert
ein solch wichtiges buch sollte nicht
als 1000 seitige lese feindlicher
philosophischer text geschrieben werden
warum haben sie es nicht für diejenigen
geschrieben die es brauchen
im laufe der fünfzigerjahre er teilweise
aufgrund dessen was in algerien geschah
ein paar kleine agieren muss man sagen
aber unabhängigkeitskampf stattgefunden
hat war die kolonie sehr blutig sehr
schlimm war hat sich in frankreich für
algeriens unabhängigkeit eingesetzt
mitte der 50er jahre also schrieb sie
eine reihe von essays die unter dem
titel privileg also privilegien
veröffentlicht wurden
ein essay beschäftigt sich mit der frage
wie privilegierte über ihre situation
nachdenken können sie kritisiert darin
intellektuelle die mit ihrem nachdenken
und schreiben über verschiedene ideen
und den sinn des lebens nur diejenigen
erreichen die ähnlich gebildet und
bibliophile sind so eine million
blindheit die man eben entwickelt man
sieht nicht die privilegien die einem
ermöglichen der zu sein der mann ist
genau
interessanterweise nimmt sie zur selben
zeit auch das projekt wieder auf über
ihr eigenes leben zu schreiben die mir
in einer tochter aus gutem hause wurden
1958 mit einem kleinen vermerk
veröffentlicht dass sie damit die
theorie des anderen geschlechts auf ihr
eigenes frau werden anwenden möchte also
praktisch eine selbstuntersuchung ihres
eigenen werdegang es im lichte ihrer
philosophie haben sehr spannendes und
das becken sind ja auch diese biografien
keine
wichtigen biografien sondern eher
psychologische erklärungen was es heißt
eine frau im zwanzigsten jahrhundert zu
sein dass an ihrem eigenen beispiel man
kann es literarisch als einen
bildungsroman über die selbst ergreifung
einer frau lesen sie ist sie selbst
geworden und sie sagt explizit dass dies
ohne psychoanalytische theorie oder
philosophischen tagungen geschildert
werden soll
nach dieser publikation kehrten die
leserinnen in großer zahl zum anderen
geschlecht zurück die briefe sind nun
ganz andere
sie loben sie dafür vom podest herunter
gestiegen zu sein
die frauen schreiben ihr ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass sie sein könnten wie ich
bei allem was wir erreicht haben aber
sie beschreiben so viele dinge die
ähnlich sind aber das vertrauen wir
heute auch im feministischen diskurs
auch oft sie würden das oft hören als
vermisst philosoph ist eine weiße frau
aus england sie können ja gar nicht
wissen was uns frauen in mexiko und
venezuela im kongo wirklich betrifft
weil sie diese erfahrungen nicht haben
ist das denn eigentlich ein gutes
philosoph los argument ich denke es ist
kein argument in den briefen dieser
frauen in einem gewissen maß sind wir
alle voneinander getrennt durch unsere
erfahrungen durch diese briefe erhält wo
war einblick in die situation ihrer
leserinnen sie erzählen wir dass sie all
das was von ihnen erwartet wurde gemacht
hätten
sie hatten den netten mann geheiratet
und hatten ihre drei kinder
aber sie fühlten sich im inneren leer
ein video das sie gezeigt haben spricht
sie über diese frauen die zu hause
isoliert vereinsamen
die sicht auf die welt aus dieser
perspektive hat ihre augen für das los
vieler normaler französin geöffnet und
sie politisch aufgeschreckt so dass sie
sich für verschiedene französische
befreiungsbewegungen engagiert ist ja
interessant an dieser sequenz die wir
gezeigt haben dass sie so eine starke
trennung macht zwischen dem öffentlichen
leben auf der straße und dem privaten
leben und das argument ist die
privatisierung der frau heißt sie zu
entpolitisieren
das könnte man sagen heute halt
dass viele frauen für eine politische
aktion ein hashtag zu hause weiter zu
senden dass diese ganze konzentration
ist ja gar nicht mehr so die gleiche mit
dieser trennung zwischen öffentlich und
privat
nein es ist nicht die gleiche situation
es hat sich viel geändert und ihre
analyse mag uns diesbezüglich veraltet
erscheinen aber ihr denken hat diese
veränderungen mit befördert und fragen
aufgeworfen wie politisch ist das
privatleben warum hat die pflege im
gegensatz zur bezahlten arbeit keinen
wert in der gesellschaft haben sie das
gefühl dass beide war der fall und das
wäre ja ein sehr produktiver fall einer
denkerin die die grundlagen dafür gelegt
hat über sich selbst hinaus zu denken
das heißt dass sie heute nicht mehr
aktuell ist aber dass es eine wirkung
ihres denkens ist dass das nicht der
fall ist
bestimmte passagen des anderen
geschlechts sind auch heute noch aktuell
sie sagen es besonders die analyse der
widersprüchlichen liebes mieten wir
lesen vielleicht nicht mehr ist totalen
oder claudel aber wir kennen neue
klischees die problematische botschaften
verstärken fernsehfilme zeigen oft
intelligente erfolgreiche frauen in der
nebenhandlung sieht man dann aber dass
ihr privatleben im argen liegt
die idee dass eine frau unabhängig von
ihrem liebesleben oder ihrer mutterrolle
ihre eigenen projekte verfolgt und
gleichzeitig andere menschen in einer
art liebt die sie als sinnvoll erachtet
naja ich treffe nicht oft menschen die
ich hier beides bewunderung
vielleicht liegt der fehler bei mir also
diese beschreibung des mythos der
weiblichen liebe der ist sehr aktuell
was würden sie sagen das können wir
nicht mehr brauchen dass es einfach in
seiner zeit situiert aber das ist vorbei
er hat selber eingeräumt dass sie den
materiellen bedingungen von frauen mehr
aufmerksamkeit hätte schenken müssen als
sie das im ersten band des anderen
geschlechts tat auch der teil zur
biologie ist stellenweise veraltet wenn
sie aber über die unabhängige frau und
über die sexuelle objektiv führung von
frauen spricht eine wesentliche aspekt
der unterdrückung der frauen dazu sehr
schwach dafür gemacht was das bedeutet
im blick des anderen zum objekt zu
werden
ja sie hat uns darauf aufmerksam gemacht
aber spannend ist trotz ihres engagement
pornografie und sexistische
verächtlichmachung wie die
verunglimpfung von juden und schwarzen
für illegal zu erklären wird sie
aufgrund ihres lebenswandels in den
dreißiger jahren immer noch als
zügellose frau gesehen und weniger als
eine feministin die dachte frauen in
einer gesellschaft ohne sexuelle
objektivierung während freier sie selbst
zu werden
da gibt es ein zitat ganz am ende dieses
buches das mir sehr kraftvoll stehen
dass ich noch mal gerne vorlesen wollte
da schreibt sie nämlich dass den was
ideal eines liebes aktes des freien
austausches in der sich mann und frau in
ihren sexuellen bedürfnissen als
ebenbürtig erkennt und dann kommt ein
satz der mir sehr zu denken gegeben hat
zitat doch paradoxerweise fällt ist der
frau viel schwerer als dem man ein
individuum des anderen geschlechts als
ebenbürtig an zu kennen das wird sie als
ob sie sagen würde die männer schaffen
das vielleicht aber die frauen aus
dieser beschreibung der frau heraus die
schaffen das nicht sind komische analyse
also da stolpert man drüber ich sie
richtig verstanden
sie denken frauen verallgemeinern männer
hat sein sie schreibt dass es für die
frau als frau schwere ist ein mann als
individuum anzuerkennen als andersherum
am ende dieses buches
sie kann ja nicht überall recht haben
eine allgemeine rungen über männer und
frauen liegt sie manchmal falsch einer
meine einwände zum anderen geschlecht
wäre dass ihre sätze oft zu weit gefasst
sind einige frauen mögen damit
schwierigkeiten haben aber nicht alle
frauen wie auch einige männer sich
moralisch problematisch verhalten aber
nicht alle männer um den satz
wohlwollend zu betrachten verstehe ich
sie so aufgrund deiner kindheit als frau
konditioniert wirst zu glauben dass dein
schicksal und der sinn deines lebens
davon abhängen von jemanden geliebt zu
werden kann ein mann zum instrument
werden und dank dem dieses schicksal
erreicht wird das ist auch unethisch
ihre ethische kritik im anderen
geschlecht richtet sich nicht
ausschließlich an männer
sie glaubt dass die identifizierung mit
geltenden mythen den frauen auch
bestimmte vorteile bringt so kritisiert
sie das anders als andere unterdrückte
gruppen frau und nicht wir sagen weil
sie sich oft mit der klasse der männer
identifizieren mit denen sie verbunden
sind
jetzt habe ich das verstanden das war
für mich wirklich jetzt ein wichtiger
erkenntnisfortschritt wir haben dieses
diese sendung die befreite genannt weil
wo war jemand war der die muster ihre
eigenen unterdrückung erkannt hat
teilweise gebrochen hat und teilweise
sich davon auch gelöst hat trotzdem
würde man sagen dass die befreite ein
guter titel ist anders gefragt hatte war
es wirklich geschafft die systematiken
die sie selbst zur frau damit zu
unterdrückten machten vollkommen von
sich zu weisen insbesondere auch in
ihrer beziehung zu sagte das ist eine
sehr interessante frage
dieses letzte kapitel heißt auf deutsch
die befreite frau auf französisch aber
heißt es leifermann dependancen
ich denke sie glaubt an eine bestimmte
form der unabhängig
die ethisch ist ich sag's am besten so
es ist eine vorbedingung für eine
moralisch richtige abhängigkeit weil
beziehungen aufgrund unserer
verletzlichkeit eine gewisse art der
abhängigkeit vom anderen mit sich
bringen aber um sich selber auf ethische
art hinein geben zu können muss man
diesen grad an unabhängigkeit erreicht
haben um nicht zu instrumentalisieren
zur frage zur seite ich sehe ihre
beziehung als eine intellektuelle
beziehung im buch wieder lege ich den
mythos dass sie auch nach zehn jahren
noch eine liebesbeziehung im
konventionellen sinn pflegten
ich bespreche auf die gründe weshalb
bewahrt schon vorher eine tiefe
frustration empfand aber sie hatten
immer noch eine unglaubliche
intellektuelle beziehung meine vorige
aussage zu wird urteilen über ihre
beziehung zu wiederholen
es gibt so einiges was ich persönlich
problematisch finde aber es ist
unbestreitbar dass sie einander
bestärkten sie sind als paar für viele
so inspirierend gerade weil sie einander
zu ihren jeweiligen projekten so
ermutigt haben
es ist eines der großen mythischen
intellektuellen parat das 20 jahrhundert
vielleicht die große philosophische
liebe das 20 wenn sie jetzt studentin
haben oder vielleicht auch eine tochter
was wäre denn der eine satz und der eine
gedanke wo sie sagen das möchte ich
weitergeben das scheint mir sehr wichtig
an dieser frau einsatz von ihr
beschreibt sehr gut die spannung
zwischen dem öffentlichen leben und dem
privatleben einer frau von ihrem format
öffentlichkeit entstellt diejenigen die
ihr in die hände fällt
ist eine legende sie ist eine
feministische ikone ihr buch das andere
geschlecht ist eine ikone und nicht alle
die sich auf das buch berufen haben es
gelesen
entsprechend einstellt öffentlichkeit
diejenigen die ihr in die hände fallen
kapazität des werkes des hvn tod heims
wir haben jetzt ein öffentliches ein
public gespräch geführt
ich bin ganz sicher es hat uns nicht zu
sehr verstellt sondern hat vieles
freigelegt über diese wichtige frau und
ihr werk und auch ihr wundervolles buch
vielen dank dass sie heute da waren
fraglich fängt hier und nächste woche
sehen sie an dieser stelle bereits um 10
uhr in der sternstunde religion einen
film über die geiselnahme von mekka vor
genau 40 jahren ein ereignis das bis
heute nachwirkt und jetzt gleich blick
wir dem schweizer maler albrecht
schnider über die schulter und sehen zu
wie er ein bild malt und ist immer
wieder wegwischt bis zu den magischen
moment wo es lässt bleiben sie also dran
und denken sie weiter
[Musik]